Мар'яна безугла своїми заявами постами
насмішками вона сьогодні підриває
обороноздатність держави як мінімум вона
мала би втратити свої посади в комітеті
бажано щоб її було виключено з комітету
з питань безпеки і оборони зокрема як це
пропонував і Федір веніславський вже
давно за її чергові там ляпи в інтернеті
Ну і за за побажання розстрілювати
військовослужбовців за непослуг а
найкращий варіант було те щоби вона не
була народною депутаткою і щоби
президент Зеленський взявся відповідати
нарешті
дії тих кого Він привів до влади Він же
ж обіцяв що якщо буде повна дурня якщо
будуть
повні неспівставні з державотворчістю
речі від конкретних депутатів вони не
мають бути депутатами Ну я думаю що це
якраз дуже кричущий випадок тому що її
заяви її пости дискредитують і
Президента України